.
>> WELCOME TO HANTY AND BREAKING
TONIGHT MOMENTUM FOR REPUBLICANS
IN KEY RACES ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
WE'RE GOING TO BREAK DOWN THE
LATEST POLLS THAT'S COMING UP
STRAIGHT AHEAD.
ALSO, PENNSYLVANIA SENATE
CANDIDATE DR. RUSSELL WILL BE
HERE WITH A SPECIAL MESSAGE FOR
THE RADICAL SOCIALIST TRUST FUND
BRAT IN A HOODY.  FOR OFFICE
NEVER FIRST WE BEGIN AGAIN IN
BEAUTIFUL MARTHA'S VINEYARD,
WHERE AFTER A WHOLE 24 HOURS OF
INTENSE EMERGENCY VIRTUE
SIGNALING, WHILE THE ISLAND'S
UBER WEALTHY, UBER-WOKE
RESIDENTS, THEY BOOTED ALL OF
THEIR NEWLY ARRIVED GUESTS OUT
OF TOWN.  THEY'RE GONE.
AS OF 8 O'CLOCK A.M. THIS
MORNING THE 50 ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WHO FLEW IN FROM
FLORIDA WERE ROUNDED UP, LOADED
ON TO BUSES AND SHIPED TO A
MILITARY BASE.
HOW LOVING, THOUGHTFUL, AND ACAM
DATING OF THE LEFT.
ACCORDING TO LOCAL DEMOCRATS,
THERE JUST WASN'T ENOUGH ROOM ON
THE 55 THOUSAND ACRE ISLAND FOR
THE 50 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, NOT
OUR PROBLEM.
THEY WERE SAYING.
YOU HAVE THE LIBERAL RACIST
XENOPHOBIA, LET'S SAY
MILLIONAIRES, BILLIONAIRES WHO
LIVE ON THE ISLAND.  THEY JUST
SAY THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO ACAM DATE THEM.
I'M NOT BUYING THAT.
OVER AT MSDN CISH YOU HAVE CHECK
TODD SAYING THAT THE SITUATION
WAS INHUMANE BECAUSE OF A LACK
OF INFRASTRUCTURE.  WHAT ABOUT
TEXAS AT 1. 1,000,000,000
ILLEGALS THIS YEAR ALONE?
NEVER MIND THE NEARLY 2 MILLION
LAST YEAR.
NOW, IT'S NOT CLEAR IF CHUCK WAS
WORRIED ABOUT THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS OR THE LONG SUFFERING
RESIDENT, THE WEALTHY IN MA'S
VINEYARD WHO WERE FORCEED TO
ENDURE A WHOLE WHAPPING 24 HOURS
OF UNINVITED GUESTS.
NOW, EITHER WAY, IT IS CLEAR
TONIGHT THAT AMERICA'S VIRTUOUS
LIBERALS ARE NO LONGER ABLE TO
IGNORE THE -- THEY KNOW JUST WHO
TO BLAME.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S A STUNT USING HUMAN
BEING TO SCORE POLITICAL POINTS.
>> I THAT THE WORD INHUMANE WAS
A GOOD ONE TO USE IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE.  PEOPLE THAT
DON'T WHERE THEY'RE GOING, THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE THERE DON'T KNOW
YOU'RE COMING.
>> SOME POLITICIANS WOULD NOT
ONLY HAVE AN ISSUE BUT
EXACERBATE IT TO AN EXTENT OF
LITERALLY HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
>> IT'S ALL DUE TO TREATING
PEOPLE AS POLITICAL PAWNS
LEAVING SOME MIGRANTS REPORTED
BY NPR.
THAT DOESN'T HAVE ANY
INFRASTRUCTURE DESIGNED TO HELP
THEM AT ALL.
IN A WORD, IT'S INHUME ABE.
>> INSTEAD OF WORKING WITH US ON
SOLUTIONS, REPUBLICANS ARE
PLAYING POLITICS WITH HUMAN
BEINGS, USING THEM AS PROPS.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS SIMPLY
WALK.
IT'S ONUNAMERICAN, IT'S
RECKLESS, AND WE HAVE A PROCESS
IN PLACE TO MANAGE MIGRANTS AT
THE BORDER.
>> PUT THEM IN JOE'S CAGES IN
THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC?
REALLY?
LET'S TALK ABOUT TRAFFICKING
BECAUSE JOE HAS BEEN DOING IT
THE ENTIRE TIME EN THE DARK OF
NIGHT.
PUTTING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ON
PLANES AND LANDING AT 2, 3, 4
A.M.
IS HE A HUMAN TRAFFICKER?
IS HE AIDING AND ABETTING
LAWBREAKING?
BY THE WAY, IT ALSO GETS WORSE.
OUT IN CALIFORNIA, YOU GOT THE
WELL NOT SO BRIGHT GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOME HE WANT RON
DESANTA ARRESTD FOR KIDNAPPING.
GAVIN NEWSOME IS SO STUPID AND
SO STRUNG OUT ON HIS OWN
INWOKENESS THAT HE SOME HOW IN
ABLE TO SEE THE REAL CRIME
COMMITTED RIGHT IN FRONT F HUM.
NOW PRESIDENT BIDEN SWORE AN
OATH TO UPHOLD THE LAWS OF THIS
LAND AND OUR CONSTITUTION.
AND YET SO FAR JOE HAS REFUSE TO
ENFORCE THE LAWS OF THE LAND AND
THAT WOULD MEAN SECURING OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THIS IS A OF DUTY, THREE PLUS
MILLION ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS HAVE
SIMPLY WALKED ACROSS THE BORDER,
UNSURER, IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
LESS THAN TWO YEARS.
NOW THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
TRANSPORTED UP TO 7 HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF THEM ON LATE-NIGHT
PLANE RIDES.  OR IN OTHER WORDS,
HE'S BEEN INVOLVED IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND AIDING EXPO
BETTING LAWBREAKING.
HE'S ALSO SEPT OTHERS ON BUS
TRIPS ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND HE GIVES PREFERENTIAL
TREATMENT.  NO COVID TESTS FOR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, NO VACCINE
MANDATES, MANY WITHOUT EVEN A
BACKGROUND CHECK TO SEE IF THEY
HAVE RADICAL ASSOCIATIONS.
YOU GOTTA PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT
AND THEY GET A FREE JOE BIDEN
PHONE.
NOW MEAN WHILE, A OR 66 KNOW
TERRORISTS HAVE BEEN CAUGHT JUST
TRYING TO CROSS THIS YEAR.
WE HAVE NO IDEA HO MANY
TERRORISTS MAY HAVE ALREADY
SNUCK INTO THIS COUNTRY
UNDETECTED.
THAT IS AN UNMITIGATED SECURITY
DISASTER.
NOW BIDEN DID DEDETAIN THOUSANDS
OF CHILDREN AND HE PUT THEM IN
THE CAGES THAT WE SHOWED YOU
THAT HE DIDN'T WANT US TO SHOW
YOU FOR A GOOD WHILE RIGHT AT
THE HEIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC.
GAVIN NEWSOME DOESN'T CARE
BECAUSE GAVIN NEWSOME IS TOO
STUPID TO REALIZE WHAT'S EVEN
GOING ON.
TODAY FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON
DESANTIS HAD THESE NICE WORDS TO
SAY.
>> THE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA
SEB A LETTER TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE SAYING YOU FEED TO
PROSECUTE TEXAS AND FLORIDA
GOVERNORS AND ALL I CAN SAY IS I
THING HIS HAIR GEL IS
INTERFERING WITH HIS BRAIN
FUNCTION.
>> THAT THE LINE OF THE WEEK FOR
SURE.
IT SUMS UP WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A LOT MORE
ON CALIFORNIA'S HALF-BAKED
GOVERNOR STRAIGHT AHEAD TONIGHT.
FIRST, LET'S GET BACK TO THE OH,
SO COMPASSIONATE RESIDENTS, THE
MILLIONAIRES THE BILLIONAIRES
INCLUDING THE OBAMAS, THEY HAVE
30 ACRES IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
WHY NOT TAKE 15 OF THOSE ACRES
AND BUILD FACILITIES FOR THE
HOMELESS PEOPLE?
BY THE WAY, THOSE PEOPLE ON
MARTHA'S VINEYARD COULD NOT BE
BOTHERED TO ACCOMMODATE EVEN 50
NEW GUESTS.
THEY WERE THROWN OUT 8 A.M. THIS
MORNING.
APPARENTLY THE GOOD TECHS OF
MARTHA VINEYARD ARE NOT FAMILIAR
WITH A LITTLE TOWN IN TEXAS
NAMED EAGLE PASS.
UNLIKE MARTHA VINEYARD, EAGLE
PASS IS THE HOME TO LESS THAN 30
THOUSAND ILLEGAL RESIDENTS.
EAGLE'S PASS IS FORCED TO DEAL
WITH HUNDREDS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS EVERY SINGLE DAY OF
THE YEAR AT ANY POINT IN TIME
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN AND AROUND EAGLE'S
PASS.
NOW, EVERY TOWN AND EVERY CITY
CLOSE TOO BORDER HAS EXPERIENCED
THE EXACT SAME HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS FOR NEARLY TOO LONG --
TWO LONG YEARS.
THAT INCLUDES EL PASO, WHEREAS
WE SPEAK THERE IS A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS HUNDREDS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT MEN, WOMEN, AND
CHILDREN THAT ARE NOW SLEEPING
IN THE STREET, THEY HAVE NO
SHELTER, NO BATHROOM, NO SHOWER,
NO FOOD, IS THIS MORE HUMANE FOR
CHUCK TODD AND THE WOKE LEFT?
IS THIS WHAT YOU PREFER
IMMIGRANTS TO BE?
LOOK AT THE CONDITIONS THEY'RE
LIVING IN.  DID YOU FORGET ABOUT
DEL RIO, ARE YOU LOOKING AT EL
PASO, AND DON'T FORGET RECENTLY
60 MILES WEST OF EAGLE'S PASS,
THOUSANDS OF HAITIANS LIVED IN
SQUALLER UNDER THAT BRIDGE FOR
WEEKS IN A MAKE SHIFT SHANTY
TOWN.
NONE OF THESE AREAS HAVE ANY
INFRASTRUCTURE TO HOUSE JOE
BIDEN'S TENS OF THOUSANDS AND
MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THEY DON'T HAVE DOZENS OF
MILLIONAIRES OR BILLIONAIRES
EITHER WITH UNLIMITED RESOURCES
A MASS OF HOMES AND LOTS OF
ACREAGE LIKE THE OBAMAS.
ALMOST NO ONE WHO LIVES HERE IS
WELL-CONNECTED OAR POWERFUL AND
YET THESE COMMUNITIES IN SOUTH
TEXAS AND ARIZONA, WHAT, THEY'RE
JUST EXPECTED TO SUCK IT UP?
DEAL WITH IT AND GET LECTURED BY
THE ELITES IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD?
THEY CAN ENJOY THEIR MAN CURED
GROUNDS MANICURED GROWNS AND
LUXURIOUS AND NOT BE BOTHERED BY
THE PEOPLE SENT BY RON DE SANTIS
WITHOUT MIGRANTS TO RUSE RUIN
THEIR REST AND RELAXATION AND
OCEAN FRONT VIEWS.
THESE ARE THE VERY SAME ELITE
AMERICANS WHO OPENED THE
BORDERS, TOLD MIGRANTS TO COME
IN DROVE, THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
BLOCKED THE BORDER WALL, ENDED
DONALD TRUMP'S SUCCESSFUL STAY
IN MEXICO POLICY, BROUGHT BACK
CATCH AND RELEASE ON STEROIDS,
NOW IT'S PROCESS AND RELEASE.
THEY CAUSED THE CRISIS AND THE
PEOPLE OF.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE PEOPLE
OF SOUTH TEXAS.  THE PEOPLE IN
ARIZONA.
THE PEOPLE IN NOVEMBER ENOUGH.
IN 53 DAYS, YOU CAN VOTE ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE OUT AND WE CAN
RESTORE OR ORD